Trump's words coming back to bite him
our K-File
just unearthing example
after example of the former president
on the record
railing against accusations
of destroying evidence
when the allegations,
of course, were limited to someone else.
Hillary Clinton in this case
and prosecutors, of course, alleged
Trump employees
Walt Nauta and Carlos
De Olivera
attempted to delete
surveillance footage at Trump's request
after the Justice Department
issued a subpoena for the footage.
Here's
some of what our K-file found
that Trump has said about this
very issue.
When it came to Hillary Clinton.
She even created
an illegal private email server.
Then she deleted 33,000 emails
to try and cover her tracks.
33,000 deleted or gone.
Remember, they used to say,
wipe the server What about the server?
What about the server?
How did that happen?
She deleted her emails.
People go to jail
for that
Andrew Kaczynski
is the senior
editor of the K File, joins me now.
So, Andrew,
those are just a few of the examples
that you have unearthed
of Trump's hypocrisy. Just a few. Yeah.
And it seems like
at every different step
of this
investigation, there's a new Trump
hypocrisy angle.
First it was when this investigation
was first starting
all of
those calls that we found that
he made
for lengthy jail sentences,
first for Clinton
and then for people
in his own
administration who he alleged had
mishandled classified information.
Then when we saw this indictment,
it was those past attacks
that he made on Clinton
at the end of that 2016 campaign
where he was saying
basically that if somebody, a president
was under a felony indictment,
it would grind the government to a halt.
He said it would create an on constant,
unprecedented constitutional crisis.
And then we finally see with
with these clips
where he's talking about,
you know, Clinton wiping the server.
We see that hypocrisy there.
Take a listen to this other comment
on Clinton from 2016
They even took a hammer
to some of her 13 phones
to cover up her tracks
in obstruction of justice.
These email records were destroyed
after she received a subpoena.
I remember that word after after
she received a subpoena from Congress
to turn them over.
If you do that in private enterprise,
it's a violation of the law.
She did this after receiving a subpoena
from the United States Congress,
which, of course, is what they are saying
is very, very exacting.
He did.
And, you know, she's the hammer,
the infamous hammer.
We don't know what he wanted them to do
with this surveillance footage.
We know that they seem
to have had of some level of incompetence
not actually succeeded at deleting it,
which is sort of an interesting twist
to this.
And so much of the special counsel's case
has been bolstered,
even in this case,
the surveillance video. Right.
Andrew, by text messages. Right.
They put them in the indictment
and you're literally reading
the actual conversation
that people had on text.
And you found a very specific example
of Trump
warning against this very thing,
putting anything in writing.
Yeah.
There's a very famous line
on the show,
The Wire, where they're talking about
not taking notes
of a criminal conspiracy theory.
And this seems to be advice
that Trump himself in
the past has talked about taking
when he's talking about,
well, you didn't have text messages
when he made these comments in 2005.
He's talking about email
take a listen to Trump
basically saying, you know,
don't put anything in writing
What really fascinates me is email.
I have friends.
First of all, half of my friends
are under indictment right now
because they send emails to each other
about how they're screwing people or not.
Right.
But it's unbelievable.
Why do people email is on
your talk on the phone.
They can't even say hello.
They don't want to say hello or goodbye.
Right.
And yet they'll write you a message
that they're having sex with 15 different
married women.
It's unbelievable.
So that was then.
This is now.
And it's going to be interesting
to see how this stuff plays out
as the case goes on. Right.
Because as I said, you're
just reading the text message.
It's like reading a novel,
except for, of course,
these are factual texts
that the special counsel's obtained.
All right, Andrew, thank you very much.
Unearthing all of this.
Now let's
go to Stephanie
Grisham, the former Trump White House
press secretary.
So, Stephanie,
the irony of these comments
are the files uncovered.
You know,
you've heard from Trump over
and over over the years, right?
This obsession
with Hillary Clinton and the server
and that lock her up.
Right.
I mean, it was the chant of his campaign,
but it all takes on new meaning. Now,
Yeah, you're right, Erin.
Thanks for having me. By the way.
It was as interesting
as I was listening to those clips,
I was considering
who was the audience
that Trump was talking to
when he was talking
about Hillary Clinton.
And it was
when he was running for office.
He office.
He was he was talking to people.
He wanted to vote for him.
And it just hit me
literally 3 seconds ago
The people who are running against Trump
should be doing this exact same thing.
They should be using his his own words,
but against him
and getting that very audience
to understand the hypocrisy
and also the deep amount of trouble
that he's in right now
with all of the investigations.
But, you know, aside from Chris Christie
and a little bit
from Will Hurd,
you have not heard from any other
Republican candidates really,
you know, sweat
slapping him
the way he would slap Hillary
on a daily basis.
Well, and we know from the indictment,
of course, Stephanie,
that Trump spoke to Carlos
Olavarria, his codefendant.
Now, he spoke to them on the phone
for roughly 24 minutes.
And after that conversation,
Olavarria tells another
Mar-A-Lago employee
that the boss wants
the security footage deleted.
And yet deliverer even now,
Stephanie has not yet turned on Trump.
Why do you think he is
so willing to risk everything for Trump?
And, by the way. Well, not appears to be.
You know, I
think that this is a design
that Trump does to people.
I think he chooses and selects
vulnerable people to to surround him.
And I'm putting myself in that
in that group by the way.
You know, if you think about this
new gentleman
who I've never seen at Mar
a Lago and I spent a lot of time there,
when you consider him
the fact that he started as a valet
he worked his way up.
He really owes Trump.
This is what he does.
He chooses people who
they work their way up
and we feel ingratiated towards him
and like we owe him
And then it's really scary.
The thought of turning on Trump
right now.
His lawyer is being paid for right now
and he has a job.
You get out into that world
without the Trump cushion.
And it's very scary
and it's not very friendly.
I've got to tell you, it's not lucrative.
And you have to think about
how am I going to support my family?
How will I ever pay
for these legal bills?
And so, you know,
I think it's
a very basic necessity of survival
that somebody like Carlos wouldn't
turn on Trump.
It's pretty incredible.
And of course, now
possibly looking at very, very serious
prison time in those security footage.
Please.
Carrie, I believe 20 years is a maximum.
So he's got very serious
decisions to make.
Thank you, Stephanie.
I appreciate it, as always.